basketball is a stage and people want to
see what i could do they want to see me
perform anywhere i go whether it's a gym
arena i have to show why i'm here
i noticed somebody that's like
man who's that look who's that little
dude
[Music]
my name is jamani swanson aka hot shot i
stand four foot five i'm the shortest
harlem globetrotter in harlem gold
charter history now i'm going into my
fourth season as a harlem globetrotter
i started playing basketball when i was
a baby literally my mother has pictures
of me
sleeping with the basketball no pacifier
and no bottle that was the first thing i
fell in love with
the gold chairs discovered me by my
videos on the internet
they had an interview with and their
biggest question was can you handle the
attention and i said i live in new york
city
i deal with it every day the attention
won't be any different than i already
experienced and they loved it
so my basketball career every time i'm
on the court i'm underestimated you know
nobody see the behind the scenes the
work that i put in
the hours the times i didn't get picked
the time that i got cut the times that
coach didn't play me because
he felt that because this kid was taller
than me that he was better than me
but i'm quick and i have amazing handles
with the basketball so
your ankles could get broken and you
know i send a lot of people to the
emergency room
[Music]
so how y'all doing
i love kids i love being around kids
because kids could relate to me more
they've probably never seen a little
person and they probably think the word
of the little president is [ __ ] and i
would have to speak about what's the
proper turn
and whether i'm short or not you still
always treat people with respect
i help them love their self appreciate
their self and as far as adults they are
aspired because the way i carry myself
i'm four foot five but i walk around
like i'm six foot five this is my job
right here the only advice i have is
you treat them the same respect that you
would treat the person with every size
there's people with dwarfism out there
who are doctors nascar races
football players
you know we're human it's nothing that
we can't do there's a person out there
with dwarfism that one day may become a
harlem globetrotter too when you have a
vision and you stick to it
only you can fail
i made it you know and i'm still going
[Music]